THE CANADIENS WHO DEFINITELY
NEED TO GET AOFF.
SUTER ON THE WING.
ADAM-- TO THE NET AND GREAT
SAVE MADE BY JAKE PUTS IT OFF
POST AND IN AND DETROIT'S POWER
PLAY GOALN THE OUTSIDE AROUND
ANDERSON AFTER IT.
BATS IT UP ON THE
AND FOOLED PRICE-- I
DON'T THINK HE THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO SHOOT THE PUCK AND
CAUFIELD GETS IT BACK.
GALLAGHER JOINING THE RUSH. RIS
SKATE.
HE'S LOOKING FOR ANDERSON
SEEN ON THE TAPE.
GOUT GALLAGHER DRIVING TO THE
HERE'S PETRY.
UP TO
COLE CAUFIELD SHOT, LOOSE,
SCORES!
PERREAULT'S SECOND OF THE  WAS
GOING TO BEE
ALL THE GOALS FINDING THE BACK
OF THE NET.
>> John:
IT AND NEGATE THE
ALLEN HAD TO BE SHARP WITH A
BLOCKER SAVE.
THAT ONE FLOATS IN THE AIR AND
IT HIT THE CORNER OF THE POST
RASMUSSEN CAN'T JAM IT IN.
HELD ITMAKE PASSES.
AND THEY ARE JUST ERRANT.
AND THIS O
HERE'S CARTER ROWNEY.
PASS ACROSS. THE LIGHTNING TRA
>> John: FABLL.
HE'S TRACKING THE PUCK WELL.
THINGS HAVEN'T